a new traffic signal is now up and
running at the intersection of Las Vegas
Boulevard and agate right near the South
Point Clark County says it's been a
dangerous intersection in fact for many
years with over 20 crashes in just the
last two years alone we decided to look
up the process that leads to new traffic
signals in Las Vegas according to the
city government website it begins with
traffic studies of the proposed area
analyzing the traffic volume speeds in
Crash history the same applies for Speed
bumps if you know of an intersection
that you feel is unsafe you can submit a
proposal to City officials to try to
launch a traffic study